[MUSIC PLAYING]
MARK MIRCHANDANI: We're
here with Tim, CTO
from Techolution,
who'll be sharing
with us a bit more
about Techolution
and how they implement Anthos.
But first, Tim, can
you tell us a bit more
about what Techolution
does and what it means
to be a Google Cloud partner?
TIM DELESIO: Sure.
Well first of all, thanks Mark
for having me on the show.
It's great to be here.
Techolution helps companies come
in, modernize their application
stack, and really come
up with a strategy
on how to get to the cloud.
And then we'll go in, set
up their cloud environment
for them, make sure it's
secure, and ready to be
deploying applications to.
And then we'll even run
manage services at the end,
if they're interested.
I work with a lot of companies.
And they really, really
want to modernize the place.
And they want to run
containers and they
want to run in their
data center or maybe
multiple cloud providers.
And the options that are out
there are really limited.
And they all have
some sort of drawback
and some sort of things
that really stop you
from working with it.
Whereas Anthos,
it really doesn't.
I mean, there's a lot of
amazing things with it.
It's based on open
source technology.
It frees you from
the vendor lock
and you can deploy
it to many clouds.
It has the power
of GKE, so it helps
you run the cloud for you.
And it really is-- it's
not that expensive.
So there's just a lot
of benefits to it.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
That makes sense
for how Anthos can help people.
But how does it actually
do those individual things?
TIM DELESIO: Anthos is
actually a collection of tools.
I should say, a collection
of mostly open source tools,
which even brings a lot
of more power to it.
So first you have GKE on
Prem, which brings you
the power of GKE and all
those benefits, like I said,
that Google brings
forward for you.
Manages the clusters for you.
It allows you that scalability.
And all the amazing things
that come along with it.
Second, you got the Anthos
configuration manager, which
is a great piece
of technology that
allows you to treat your
configurations as code so you
can check them into the
repository, make changes.
And when you want to change
or update the system,
it'll automatically
pull it down.
The next is the
Anthos Service Mesh,
which is a product
based on ISTIO, which
allows you to kind
of get some insight
into your inter-process
communication
between your containers and
get some insight into actually
what's going on.
And next on the list,
you have Cloud Run,
which is a server
list technology that
allows you to
bring the functions
and the service list benefits
you get to your data center
or to any other cloud provider.
And then finally, you
have the Marketplace.
So if you need to use third
party tools like MongoDB,
or Redis or Elasticsearch
or any of the things
that are actually
in the marketplace,
you can bring those to wherever
you're actually running Anthos.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
So it makes sense
these different
pieces kind of play
together to create a
really great solution.
TIM DELESIO: Yes, yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: For a
wide variety of use cases.
Can you talk a bit more
about how you've implemented
Anthos in a specific use case?
And like, what that
brought to the table?
TIM DELESIO: Absolutely.
Anthos is still
relatively new technology.
You know, it just
came out last April.
So people are still learning
to get their hands on it
and figure out how it works.
So we've been working
with a lot of customers.
And when they embark on
this journey by themselves,
you know, and they don't
properly plan and strategize
how they're going to do this,
they kind of run into problems.
We've saved many customers
coming in and helping
them strategize.
So we're able to come
in, set up a plan,
use some of our automation
and our IP that we've created
and help them get to
Anthos in 30 days or less.
Another good scenario
that we worked with,
which is very,
very specific one,
is we're working with a client.
And the IT operations
guy probably
had a little too much
power than he should have.
And he was working
with the environment
and he was in a qual
environment-- at least
he thought he was in
a qual environment.
But he was actually in a
production environment.
And he accidentally
deleted the namespace.
And you can't imagine what the
repercussions of that were.
So with Anthos,
if he was running
Anthos and those
Configuration Manager,
he wouldn't have
had that problem.
Because if you
delete the namespace,
it will automatically go back
to the single source of truth,
a.k.a., the repository,
pull the latest version
of whatever it was, and
rebuild the cluster for you.
So actually, after we
deployed Anthos for him,
we actually showed him this
and had him actually do it.
And he was amazed at
how quick it actually
rebuilt the cluster
right in front of him.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
I'm sure that's
a situation that unfortunately,
a lot of us can relate to.
TIM DELESIO: Unfortunately yes.
MARK MIRCHANDANI:
But it kind of gives
a good example of where
the power of Anthos
and implementing it comes from.
So for people who are interested
in maybe taking on Anthos
or learning more about
it, what are Some
of the big takeaways for them?
TIM DELESIO: Sure.
The biggest thing that I
think that you kind of don't
necessarily think about is it
really brings the cloud to you,
allows you to
modernize in place.
So if you want to run
containers and micro services,
and you want to run
that in your data center
or really any cloud
provider that you choose,
it brings that
capabilities for you.
And it brings all the power of
GKE and the management of that.
It's also great
for companies that
have problems with either
regulations, whether they
be data regulations or
government regulations,
where they've got to keep
all of the data in one place.
You can bring the
cloud to them where you
don't have to get the data out.
You know, some of
the big takeaways
that I've learned from actually
setting up and installing
Anthos is make sure that you
have full logging enabled.
I mean, you need
to be able to see
every log item that goes in,
whether it's info or to bug.
The more logging you have,
the better you'll be.
And second, you know,
when you're actually
going in and
setting this up, you
need to be really good
at recreating this.
You need to be able
to wipe it clean,
start fresh, and just keep
going and plugging away.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: It's always
great to hear these customer
stories.
So thank you so much for
coming in and telling
us a bit more about what
makes Anthos so powerful.
TIM DELESIO: Thanks Mark.
Thanks for having me.
MARK MIRCHANDANI: If
you'd like to learn more
about Techolution,
visit Techolution.com.
Thanks for watching.
And stay tuned for more
great episodes of Stack Chat.